we feel that we're finding ourselves in
the middle of a generation and maybe
even at the beginning of an era where we
struggled to sit down and have a
difficult conversation oftentimes I
don't believe that echo chambers force
you to interrogate your own beliefs and
censorship doesn't foster personal
growth but I believe that these things
can only be accomplished through
conversation through civil discourse
which is exactly what we're hoping to do
here tonight we're hoping to reestablish
a culture of conversation on this campus
where neighbors can disagree often to
the core of their beliefs and stand out
from that conversation stand up from
that table and walk away and still come
together knowing that we're all part of
the same community that we're all
Wildcats and so with that we invite you
Turning Point invites you everyone here
from the left of the aisle to the right
the front of the room to the back
everyone in here and outside to join in
this conversations in this conversation
and all conversations move forward to
have an open mind open ears and the
willingness to participate in civil
discussion with that I'd like you asked
join me would put your hands together
for the host of the Reuben Porte de
Reuben
thank you guys Wow I gotta tell you guys
I did not think my day was gonna end up
in a hockey rink when I woke up this
morning but here we are any hockey fans
here we have some hockey fans all right
I am wearing a cup because it's a free
speech event Ted you know I asked them
if we're gonna do this at a hockey rink
can I come in on the Zamboni but
apparently you know they didn't the
turning point doesn't have the money for
that kind of thing unfortunately that's
tough look at you guys you all came out
here to a hockey rink to listen to me
talk about free speech that's pretty
cool I'm very excited you guys feeling
good all right there's more outside I
think we have room there let be a seat
back there somewhere I think we could
probably let anymore I mean it's kind of
fitting that this is sort of how we
ended up right I had a hockey rink right
now if you think about it I mean you
know all that all the officers and and
policemen that are here securing this
thing these guys are doing their jobs
doing a great job actually give them a
round of applause for making sure that
nothing crazy gonna happen I guarantee
you you're not gonna hear anything
remotely close to hate speech or
anything like that there actually is no
such thing as hate speech and we'll talk
about that too but you're not gonna hear
any hate out of me I guarantee you you
know Candace Owens who seven words
really put her on the map this week I
love the way Candace Owens thinks from
Kanye and just seemingly has has changed
the world
I actually think putting aside where
your feelings are on Kanye for a moment
I think that him saying that offering a
little oxygen for people that want to
think a little bit differently just a
little bit differently if you don't want
to just take democratic dogma or leftist
dog more progressive Dogma if you don't
want to take that as the Bible you know
as the word from God but you need a
little room to think differently and I
think you guys probably do think a
little bit differently I hope
have I can see some interesting
diversity the left loves diversity
meaning the color of your skin and your
sexuality and all that stuff in your
gender and that's all that's all well
and fine but that's actually not the
diversity that matters the diversity of
the matters is what's going on in your
head what do you actually think right I
mean imagine if I was to look at you
guys and I can just I mean I can look
any of you and think all right white guy
there you must think that black guy
there he must think that asian girl
there she must think that that actually
is the essence of prejudice okay that is
the essence of prejudice prejudice which
means to prejudge and if you look at
someone and think that you know what
they should think because of the color
of their skin or their sexuality or
anything else you actually you're the
one that is acting bigoted I mean that's
that's actually the truth that's sort of
the reverse of how it spun these days
but the only way that we can actually
have conversations the only way that we
can actually figure out what's going on
and figure out how can we really talk to
each other is if you look at people as
individuals not as a collective and this
is kind of the key to everything that's
sort of wrong with society right now
we've somehow figured out that if we
group each other right if we group each
other and we play this really awful game
of identity politics that's really the
reverse of everything that this nation
was founded upon you know think about
this for a second you guys are here
University of New Hampshire I assume oh
so you go to the University here you're
at a great school I guarantee that
virtually every single one of you have
it better than your grandparents or your
great-grandparents virtually every if
really think about it think about your
grandparents for a second think about
your great-grandparents probably didn't
know them I guarantee you what you have
at 19 20 21 years old hell over you
however old you are is is a lot better
it's a world better than the way they
had it no matter what color you are
religion you are anything and this is
what identity politics has put us up
against it's placed us in this situation
where we're grouping people based on
their immutable characteristics so if
you're black you should think this if
you're Muslim you should think this if
you're gay you should think this
this which really as you guys know this
is what intersectionality is all about
the idea behind intersectionality being
that if you take all of these groups you
can kind of put them together like a
transformer or something and that there
will become something stronger but
actually what's been proven and
everything that's happening in society
right now is that they're becoming
weaker they're actually in a sort of
oppression Olympics where they're
competing with each other for victimhood
and and victimhood is not virtue and
that's really important you know what's
virtue you guys it's what the model of
this state is Live Free or Die do
whatever yeah I mean that's what we're
kind of depressing about the fact that
we had to switch menus here I mean the
state motto is live free or die or it
goes live free or go to hockey rink but
that's what virtue is living free or die
figure out what you believe what do you
believe and fight for that relief fight
for that even by the end of this thing
and we'll do a robust Q&A and I'm happy
to hear from any of you guys that
disagree with me on all this stuff
whatever you believe if you fight for it
honestly and and using your mind and
your faculties and not because you
silence people or because you pulled
fire alarms or called in bomb threats if
you fight okay can someone shut off the
robots I don't know how we're gonna do
this
guys I got you we'll get to it do you
think anyone's here for you guys is that
what you think what's going on here guys
[Music]
I like this guy more listen that is guys
guys guys do you think anyone's here for
you do you understand what you're doing
right now hey listen listen listen
guys guys guys look at me look at me you
I mean you can at least look at me there
you go all right look look look look do
you think anyone's here for you do you
think anyone's here for you I agree
black lives matter
I agree black lives matter do not play
the quiet game we'll try it that way
guys guys you listen you got the script
down I'm gonna impress two with the
repetition you know guys okay let's try
this I see some black people in the
audience could someone ask them to be
quiet would that maybe work guys guys
come on you see thank you sister
guys guys guys you are what is wrong
with society right now you you are
proving it right now you are proving it
right now this nonsensical guys this
epic nonsensical self-righteous [ __ ]
sit down sit down yeah I know yell
louder Oh God
get laid like go do something with your
eyes so pathetic no one's here for you
yeah you know what I'll give you a
cookie if you can say something else how
about that I got a whole tray of cookies
back there no yeah do you think I don't
think black lives matter what are you
going she's checking the phone to make
sure she got the script right okay come
on now
come on you can do it you can do it take
a seat take a seat yeah okay remember
guys were the intolerant ones we are the
intolerant ones right you know you can
see all you guys getting real violent on
them you know nobody's here for them but
guys okay seriously shut the [ __ ] up
shut the [ __ ] it's pathetic you're
pathetic human beings really I'm all
about open exchange this is what I do
for a living I will gladly take all your
questions all night long
you are what is wrong with society you
serve right there you are what's wrong
with society and you ma'am you what's
wrong with society I know the police are
happy to kick you guys out well just
refresh me for a sec what were you
saying again cuz I yeah just relax relax
okay I believe black lives matter I
believe every life matters I believe
that we should not be prejudiced towards
everyone anyone and we should not have
laws that are dictated that are
different for anyone we should be
treating everyone equal that is the
beauty of America I'm gonna talk to my
friends right here the beauty of this
country is that people from every walk
of life have come here no matter the
color of their skin or their religion or
whatever they came with look what it
says on the on the Statue of Liberty you
know what I mean she didn't say bring us
your best she said bring us your poor
your huddled masses and you know what's
happened because of the incredible
freedoms that we have given people in
this country everyone look around this
room this is diversity but it's as I
said earlier it's not just diversity of
color its diversity of thought and I'm
gonna come up here I'm gonna talk about
a lot of
things that the Conservatives aren't
happy about and conservative groups
invite me to do that so I appreciate
that you've quieted down and if you
grant me the same respect that I'll
grant you that's how you change things
but that what you just did right there
that's not how you change things it is
how you change things just not change
things for the better anyway how's it
going on this side guys anyone want to
get anything up there their chest so
this scourge of identity politics it
truly it truly is rotting away at
everything that's right with this
country the country was founded on the
idea of the melting pot right that you
come here from wherever you came
wherever you came more people have come
to America to make a better life for
themselves than any place in the history
of the world that is absolutely true
does that mean it's perfect does no does
that mean we don't we've made mistakes
absolutely does that mean that there are
n justices now of course but there is no
place which is why no one ever leaves
any of you guys planning on leaving
America yeah nobody goes even Lena
Dunham she's still here it would be nice
if she left but she's still here okay
nobody leaves and that this is the irony
so you have this set of people now who
go on and on about identity politics and
everything that's wrong with America and
where this evil patriarchy and where
this evil racist society and they demand
at the same time I love this one they
demand at the same time that we should
have open borders so that I guess the
other people can share in the horrors
that are America that is not sensible
you see what I'm saying it's not
sensible people what is sensible is
coming together regardless of what your
differences are in the only way you do
that is if you view people as
individuals that every single one of you
that I can look at you right there
looking at me with the glasses you we
were we were having a moment there
you're looking away from me okay I'll
look at somebody else how you doing
buddy right here the only way I can
judge you I know nothing about you
nothing about you I know nothing about
you but all I can figure out is that if
we had a conversation I could figure out
what you think and why you think it and
hopefully if you thought some things
that I thought were wrong
through civility I could get you to
think differently and perhaps you could
get me to think differently so let's
talk about some of our differences
actually because turning-point
rights meet all of these things and
Charlie has no problem being on stage
with me and we have plenty of
differences I am I'm for gay marriage I
even married a dude I mean that's yeah
I'm gay okay Zippity damn dude I thought
I was gonna get an applause for my
oppression but alright yeah it doesn't
matter it just doesn't matter what you
should want are equal rights so any of
you can marry whoever you want to marry
you want equal rights that's all you
want you don't want extra rights the
conservatives invite me to these places
I'm what I would describe as grudgingly
pro-choice I think it's a horrible
decision to have to make I know two
women in the last year in my life who
had to have abortions or who chose to
have abortions I know this is for the
Conservatives this is this is a bridge
too far and I've had plenty of people on
my show I had a debate with ben shapiro
about abortion and you know I've picked
20 weeks as the I like where this one's
going oh is that rain is that I'm gonna
need a little more on that one yeah is
this a local thing what's going on do
you want to ask me something yeah you
could ask me something see this is this
is what happens every time
truly ma'am if you want to ask me
something I'd love to hear a question
from you no so you don't have a question
is there anything I said that you didn't
like did you not like anything you don't
want to comment on that either you see
what's going on here I really want you
guys to understand this because this is
so consistent we can get some robots and
clones here you know repeating some
stuff and now you have a jar with a
whatever the hell you got in there and
I'm I am seriously willing to have a
conversation with you right now let's do
it let's do it but you won't question me
and you won't tell me you didn't like
anything who's winning here do you think
right now who's changing more Minds me
or you
yeah I think I think I made my point all
right yeah no it's yeah he's got some
moves over here it's not true what they
say about white people can't dance I saw
that that was very impressive
he had that two white guys have two
moves like a shoulder thing and a little
toy but see this is what's happened this
is what has led us here to the irony
this is so ironic you guys don't
remember this but ten years ago when you
guys were whatever you were 10 11 12
years old the Conservatives were the
intolerant side the Conservatives
were the ones that were screaming
against gay marriage and the
Conservatives were the one talking about
all sorts of other stuff that was
actually intolerant this is intolerant
now and you don't get extra credit for
your skin color I hate to tell you so
yeah I mean that's just how it is I I
would love to have a conversation with
you and you want to rattle around a can
okay so that's fine but this is what has
happened you guys the Conservatives the
conservative how many of you actually
consider yourselves conservatives make
some noise make surprised if you
consider yourself a turd let's do it
yeah good for you guys you're gonna have
jobs in the future you're gonna have
cars and family and property and things
and it's pretty good that's sweet all
right how many of you consider yourself
libertarian any libertarians you can you
can do Moyes instead of clapping you're
here I love I mean really fundamentally
I think I'm probably although we're
gonna talk about classical liberalism in
a second I think actually more than
anything I'm a libertarian in that I
want you to live free and I want to live
free and the only exchange that we can
have there is that basically I'm gonna
have my stuff you're gonna have yourself
and you can't just come onto my property
and take my [ __ ] as long as we'd get
that far
that's a pretty good Society and that
means that occasionally people are gonna
say things that upset you that means
that people are gonna do things that
upset you but that's the beauty of this
thing you know there are some societies
where nobody's gonna say anything that
upsets you you know where that is that's
North Korea you don't want to be there
want to be there you are gonna be upset
every now and again but you know what
words are not violence I know that the
left has tried to trick you into
thinking that because somebody says
something that upsets you that you're
either allowed to punch them or silence
them or call in a bomb threat or force a
venue to have to move but that is not
your right you have the right to free
speech and your right to free speech the
whole purpose of your right to free
speech is that you have to respect
someone else's right to free speech now
what you can do by the way is protest I
hope that there are thank you I hope
that there are protesters are or world
protestors out there with as many signs
as they want to have doing their thing
and as long as you do it peacefully and
you don't encroach on anyone else's
rights that's your supposed to do that
in a free society it's beautiful but if
you use your free speech to infringe on
somebody else's you're actually not part
of civil society at all so all right
back to the libertarian so I like the
libertarians I voted for Gary Johnson I
had Gary Johnson on my show he didn't
know his name he wasn't the best
candidate ever not a great candidate he
was the first that ever turned me
against weed because he couldn't
remember a [ __ ] thing I mean he
really was just this would have been the
year 2016 would have been the year for a
Libertarian candidate I mean we had two
of what I would say are the worst
candidates in in at least as candidates
we can talk about Trump in a second but
at least his candidates we had two of
the worst most polarizing candidates
ever and all a libertarian had to do was
come in and understand some basic [ __ ]
and Gary just dropped the ball he just
every interview it was like watching a
muppet right it's too easy to beat up on
him so forget how many of you guys
consider yourselves classical liberals
classical liberals all right a couple
classical liberals they're very
respectful that's what I like so
classical liberalism this is interesting
because people say to me well what's the
difference Dave you say you're a
classical liberal and how is that
different than being on the Left how is
that different than being a progressive
and a classical liberal basically it's
really simple if you believe in the
individual that I
was talking about before if you believe
that the government has some role to
exist that the government has to do
something but not everything so our
founders actually mostly I think were
classical liberals our founders
basically create an incredible system
where we have 50 states now and we have
a federal government that should do very
little the federal government should
make sure that you know they're taking
care of our borders they should make
sure that our states aren't warring with
each other but beyond that the federal
government actually shouldn't do that
much that if you believe in that if you
believe there's some role for government
but not some massive government that we
have then I think you're basically a
classical liberal so the classical
liberals and the libertarians are pretty
much in the same spot and ironically now
the Conservatives have sort of come in
and fit into that thing as well so
there's a pretty big tent developing on
the right while the left is just purging
every one of their free thinkers I mean
every one of their look what happened to
Kanye this week forget what you think
about Kanye forget what you think his
politics are or any of you like his
music or not it's completely irrelevant
look what happened he tweets seven words
about a relative a girl that I know and
like all out but but a relatively
unknown person in Candice Owens and
suddenly everybody the lead story on
Twitter moments was Kanye West tweets
support for far-right Candice Owens
far-right Candice Owens a black girl who
happens to be a conservative is now
far-right
all right yeah I'm with you solidarity
against hate I am with you I'm with you
guys yeah yeah yeah you guys working
with these two you guys definitely hang
out with them because I think it would
be fun I'm doing I'm with you I'm with
you guys
solidarity against hate I don't think
you should hate anyone based on their
sexuality or their Lord all right yeah
all right here we go here we go yeah
they messed up the rhythm on that when I
caught that all right yeah I got you
guys yeah let's try this how many of you
here are for hate how many of you are
for hate is anyone for hate if we're out
of hate rally here as they would have us
believe anyone for hate nobody for it
guys do you think you're helping your
cause this is what I'm trying to tell
you do you think you're helping your
cause here do you have any questions for
me I'll gladly
no question you just made a point you're
gonna let it be all right there you go
they off you do the mic so we're gonna
offer the mic for this nonsense this is
what the promised you guys see this I
mean you really need to grasp yourselves
around this and and why does this keep
happening why does this sort of endless
droning and repetitive sort of pointless
statements everyone's against hate
everyone that's sensible is against hate
but why does this keep happening and
there's a reason it keeps happening
because leftism and progressivism and
collectivism grouping people by those
immutable characteristics has been so
ingrained and taught to you guys at
colleges and it has been so rewarded by
the mainstream media and it has been
coddled you've all you guys have been
coddled to think that what you think
automatically has to be right and that
all the people that came before you had
no [ __ ] clue as to what they were
doing but some of them did some of them
did some of them are bad ideas and some
of them had good ideas and some people
in this room have bad ideas and some
have good ideas but just chanting things
because you're upset actually has no
meaning and that's why I still when we
do the Q&A at the end I will gladly go
to you guys first if you can come up
with an original thought and and tell me
what you think of something but that but
that's the truth
that sadly is the truth and that's why
oddly the right now is the home for free
thinking I'm shocked this was completely
not what I ever thought would happen but
yet that is where we are right now
what's that what do you got for me
she's mailed in something at me what do
you got what do you got oh no yeah not
bad you know
combat gent calm okay I don't even I
don't get like a referral fee on that or
anything that's that that's just the
truth but okay so look this idea of
identity politics has wrecked things I
want to give you a couple examples of
how it has done this so I assume most of
you have seen some of my shows at least
I want to mention a couple of my guests
so Jordan Peterson how many you guys
know Jordan Peterson okay Jordan
Peterson for those of you that don't
know him he was a psychology professor
at the University of Toronto for the
past 30 years or so he's done tremendous
academic work for many years really
wasn't a public person he had written
one book couple years back and about two
years ago Canada was gonna pass it
wasn't quite gonna be a law it was gonna
sort of be a directive but we know how
these things sort of operate it starts
with you know some subtle thing and then
eventually becomes a law that if you
misgendered somebody you could be fined
and then potentially this would lead to
imprisonment at some point now let's be
very clear here I am a hundred percent
for equality for trans people Jordan who
I know extremely well we're going on
tour together I'm not what I got nope I
got no problem with you I don't know
what you're talking that I have trans
friends I don't know what do you mean I
I think you should
yeah well alright
I'm only gay after 10 it's alright let's
do it you seem deaf thought so that's
pretty good so what have I said that is
that is so offensive to you I am a
hundred percent for you to have the same
exact dignity that everyone else in this
country as I am a hundred percent for
you to have every every law and legal
protection that anyone else in this
country has so what is it that you don't
want me to say that I have said here
well I was about to get to that until
you started screaming yeah well you know
what here's the thing we have the right
to free speech you don't have hang on
hand listen okay I got you I got you
okay so look you know what here's the
deal in in free Western societies you
have the right to free speech you don't
have the right to not be offended now I
am NOT for people running down the
street and and saying anything hateful
to you but really think about what
you're calling for here think about what
you're calling for here what you're
saying is that if someone walking down
the street says miss miss genders you
write that you want this person to be
fined or put in jail that's what you
think is right
is that is that correct I don't want to
put words in your mouth you're right and
you know how people should be held
accountable by themselves by their
family by their friends by their
community not the government and this
was again was the government but see how
I already got you to move on your
position there I think anyone can
understand that you wouldn't want the
government coming in and telling people
what you can and cannot say so Jordan
said I am NOT against trans people and
it's very clear to me that he's not
the earth is flat finally someone making
some sense out there so you really need
to understand this you don't you don't
have a right to be not offended I wish
we all wish that we lived in a better
place we're magically everybody was
wonderful we're magically everyone was
sweet and decent we don't live in that
world but if you think that the
government forcing people to do to act
as you wish they would act is going to
bring peace and love and harmony it
actually will only bring the complete
reverse every time in the history of the
world that the government promised
utopia it brought dystopia every time
that the government expanded to create
some magical society it brings societies
that kill millions of people so what you
should want is exactly what you have in
America right now which is that you have
equality you can have a job you can live
free I hope you have someone in your
life that you love you can have all of
those things and if the government
started cracking down on you because you
happen to be trans I will be your
biggest ally I will be out there with
you every day so you really need to be
careful what you ask for I get it
you're coming from a place where you
don't want to be hurt nobody wants to be
hurt right everybody has had bad [ __ ]
set about them everyone's got something
they're insecure about everyone's got it
but believe me the idea that the
government is going to solve that
problem it is not the way to go did we
get anywhere there I kind of felt good
about that no that's all right
this is why conversation is so important
guys right like we can just kind of yell
at each other and this is what's
happening and this is what the media
wants us to do you know you can turn on
CNN and no one in their right mind is
learning anything from CNN you turn on
CNN and you get eight screens of yelling
people who don't even know how to tie
their shoes telling you that they know
how to run the world it's all nonsense
actually the best way to watch CNN put
it on mute and put the Looney Tunes
theme song on it's far far better than
what CNN is showing you but all of but
this is what this is why you guys have
turned on to the online news however you
get your news weather
on the left and you may be watched uit
or you're on the right and you listen to
ben shapiro or whatever else it is that
there's a beautiful thing there it is
now on you guys to figure out what you
believe find sources that you care about
if you think that dave rubin is a
bigoted hateful whatever don't watch i
mean that's the beauty you don't have to
show up you don't have to support i mean
it's it's a beautiful thing i mean this
is what the exchange of freedom is all
about I feel I could I could keep going
here but I'm kind of tempted to just
jump right into the questions because it
seems like some of you guys have some
questions and I truly happy to we could
start with all people that disagree with
everything I said here so how are we
doing the questions I think there's a
couple microphones around here so we've
got some mics up there so if you've got
a question and we've got one down here
please come on down we can start with
you right there I feel like you've got
something for me yeah yeah free speech
but he's gonna hold the mic for me okay
I mean see so you see how silly you're
coming in you're coming in ready ready
to fight interesting that he's holding
the mic right why do you give her the
mic
let's look why don't you pass big win
big win okay I was serious about the
suit by the way
so you don't believe hate-speech exists
no and you the Supreme Court agrees with
me by the way great you and the rest of
the people who are here with you or who
are supposed to be here with you claim
that people have a victimhood complex
and that anything regarding racism or
sexism or whatever ISM it is that we're
talking about is fake news and everybody
is just out here wanting to be a victim
as if that's something you know that
people are spam you know I wake up every
morning and I say wow how can I be a
victim despite Dave Rubin or Charley
Kirk I just don't understand yeah like
what does it take for for you know folks
on your end of the aisle to understand
that people have lived
and who wake up every day every single
day in this country whether you think
their victimhood complex is real or not
and they don't feel like a part of this
country and you can sit and blame them
all you want but this campus is a great
example right here when we have people
on this campus who are claiming that it
is all sunshine and rainbows and they
have the administration on their side
and then the reality is that biased
incidence reports and hate crimes have
gone up yeah so and people have been
spit on and people have been threatened
and people have been told to go home to
their country even though they were born
in [ __ ] New Jersey understand like do
I have to get lynched like does somebody
have to like murder me like this
somebody have to like what will it take
for it to be hate speech and when do I
actually become a victim when I'm dead
okay all right great question great
question that's great all right it's a
great question so first off the Supreme
Court has ruled that hate speech doesn't
exist in that you can do basically you
can say whatever you want short of
yelling fire in a crowded theater or
calling for direct violence to someone
so right now you can say anything to me
you can literally say anything to me I'm
sure you're thinking of a couple things
and you can say whatever you want to me
and guess what I'll survive and that's
the price that you have to pay to live
in a free society so let me kick it back
to you for a second so first off you
there was a little miscommunication in
the way you present to that which is
racism exists I don't think racism
doesn't exist of course there are
bigoted people there are people who are
misogynist that may not like you because
you're a woman there are people that are
don't like gay people so they won't like
me there are people that are truly
prejudiced against black people and
every other situation the idea that the
government can come in and manage and
fix all of those things is crazy and we
live in a society that has done more to
free more people than any other society
truly in the history of the world but I
will kick it back to you for a second so
tell me about tell me about your
oppression I mean tell me about what
you're dealing with and how the
government can fix it it
doesn't mean that bad people don't exist
but tell me about your oppression maybe
maybe we can work through something it's
my favorite song your mom nice right
I think tell me about your oppression I
have no reason to sit and talk about my
own oppression because that's just like
mental energy I'm going to be paid to
talk about my ladies ladies ladies I'll
gladly take a question from you have we
established that already okay so so far
we have some repetitive droning
statements and then when I can't get
back to someone to ask about their
oppression she wants to be paid for it
you know I see what I got why don't you
pay me venmo me 20 bucks
I got 20 bucks I will pay you I will pay
you okay so what would you prefer what
would you prefer that the government
okay guys I get it I don't want people
to say bad things easier I wish I could
get off to the sound of my own voice
wouldn't that be awesome you seem to get
off the sound of your own voice see
you're angry you're angry and there's no
reason to be angry you're standing in
front of banging you're standing it from
someone that's truly that comes from the
place that you are in right now I was a
lefty my entire life I get it I get
interesting how you've put a political
label on me already
okay all right let's move on we tried
but really if you want to tell me your
oppression I'll give you 20 bucks first
of all yeah so easy with you guys we got
40 bucks what are you doing here you
know actually part of the part of the
freedom part of the freedom and the
contractual exchange we have as free
people living in a free society is that
you're not supposed to use your free
speech to drown out someone else's so
I'm truly asking you I am truly someone
else's free speech is infringing on your
free speech speech literally infringes
on other people's existence I just so
look you have I told you what the
boundaries are the boundaries are you
can't yell fire in a crowded theater and
you can't call directly for violence but
short of that you are allowed in a free
society and you're Jewish correct yeah
so I abhor anti-semitism
so Byron's like standard logic people
can say [ __ ] about the Jews yeah that is
espoused against Jewish people does not
promote violence against them you are
allowed to in a free society I would
prefer that people be nicer right and
that may or may not lead to violence
again
all for violence to people but what you
can do it's the exchange of freedom
would you prefer you think there's a
correlation between hating Jews and
wanting to kill them yes or no question
you're asking me quick right all right
let's move on yes or no situation over
here I would prefer that people not say
bad [ __ ] about Jews or Muslims or gay
people or anyone but the freedom I don't
want anything from you I want you to
live your life in peace do you believe
that people who say they hate Jews I
believe will not be likely to want to
attack Jews they might be but you have
the right to say mean things in a free
society is just a mean thing you know
it's just all mean things graven tell a
dead person that he was mean you can
that's freedom my ancestors who died in
a genocide are rolling in their grave
yeah I'm here practicing my First
Amendment right I'm gonna give the mic
when I put this mic down I just want you
to know that your opinion literally
means [ __ ] to me and if you agree
with the concept the straight let me get
this straight society and telling people
who they can't offend and who they can't
offend and when and when they can offend
anybody but there's a huge difference
and just normally being offended I don't
want anyone to die because they're
Jewish I'm not saying that you're saying
I have not gone I have not said a single
thing about your personal character up
until this point you have belittled me
so that I don't understand what words
mean have told me to shut up have told
me that I'm taking up space isn't that
fascinating so who really is the entire
one here because all I've done is just
talk pretty loudly on a mic because
you're the problem of the women talking
pretty loudly on a mic
[Applause]
[Applause]
somebody else can get a question because
I so graciously believe in free speech
yeah guys this is this is what it's all
about really this is what it's all about
notice in the free society that we live
but no one's coming for you now you can
post that on Twitter you can do whatever
you want it's a beautiful thing it's a
beautiful thing yeah hey Dave a big fan
just want to say start off before I get
to the question is that my parents came
from Afghanistan they escaped the day
before the Russians invaded Christmas of
1979 so they all live in America now
they love it they'd never leave
and everyday growing up you know I not
every day you know just sometimes like
my skin's a little bit darker I grew up
in a very white neighborhood I got some
offhand comments about me being Afghani
terrorist jokes everything I was like or
whatever that's how that's how I dealt
with it I said whatever I didn't
internalize my oppression as some people
thought may think I did I just really
didn't care because they're gonna make
jokes they're really not gonna go that
far because people are truly intolerant
I don't think they're gonna really go
anywhere in life so that's what I'm
saying about that is if you're truly
people who aren't ruling tolerant aren't
really gonna get anywhere and so I don't
let that stuff bother me but I wanted to
ask about Marcus Meacham do you know him
the count dank EULA the guy who that's
like how ridiculous do you think it is
for a joke about yeah that turning a pug
into an Aussie Howard is do they get is
that man was arrested his life was put
on hold for two years like I it was just
insane to me like that's completely
insane so are you all familiar with this
story so this is an online YouTube comic
who basically he was doing a joke it was
a joke and he had his his dog do the
Hitler salute now again I am NOT for the
Hitler salute I am NOT for Nazis I am
NOT for white supremacism or racism of
any kind or anything like that but the
guy made a joke and you can say it's a
shitty joke he's a bad comic it's a
tasteless joke all of those things but
in a free society you have a right to do
those things you have a right
to offend it is on you as the person on
the receiving end of that to decide
whether that is going to ruin your day
or make you stronger in what your
beliefs are or anything else so it's by
the way the real issue with this is
every one of us every one of us even if
you just hate me every one of us should
be thanking whatever you believe in that
we are here we have the protections he
would have been able to do that in the
United States now you may not like it
again but we have the protections that
allow you to live your life to the
maximum potential in this country we
live in a place that a young guy whose
parents came from Afghanistan a war-torn
country can come here and not make
excuses and do everything that you want
to do in your life and you're gonna do
amazing things I have no doubt about it
that is a beautiful thing you have no
desire to play the victim you're gonna
go out there and bust your ass and yes
will there be someone that you might
want to work for that's gonna go wow
he's got brown skin and I'm a racist and
I'm not gonna hire him that might happen
it might but you know what someone else
will find you and the more that these
companies if there's a big company out
there that's saying we're not gonna hire
this person or that person based on skin
color or based on race they will crumble
look what's happening in Silicon Valley
right now it's actually amazing it's
amazing what's happening in Silicon
Valley right now Peter Thiel is leaving
Silicon Valley because leftist you got
to work on getting that oh she's got a
backup it's incredible leaving Silicon
Valley because leftism has caused the
situation where they cannot even think
straight
they cannot come up with new ideas
that's why there are no new apps where's
the new Twitter where's the new snapchat
where's the new Facebook it can't come
out of a group thing
so whatever you even do in your life
you're gonna do great things I have no
doubt yeah
why'd we go right here red jacket I did
yep my question is you're trying to lead
a civil discourse day of it and why is
it that some people believe that it's
okay to be disrespectful and interrupt
so that some of us can't hear the
presentation and hear other questions
and hear your views on things yeah I
don't know that I'm the right guy to be
asking that I will gladly I will gladly
talk to all these people I mean really
that's how the way you change minds the
way you change minds of guys is you you
sit with people and you try to explain
your position not trying to drown out
people I mean that's just that's just
how it's done in every in every safety
what's that
you can't yes you can you're right no
but you're right you can do it notice no
one's coming for you nobody's coming for
you no one's silencing you but do you do
you have a question or a comment do you
have a question or a comment yeah yeah
alright I mean this is what happens
every time and but partly what's going
on here guys is that the reason to
critically think has become so
degradation okay
the reason it's become so so hurtful to
hear words is because the left has owned
all of the places of learning for so
long that every time someone comes in
and says I believe in low taxes or I
believe in something that's a little bit
out of leftist mainstream people
immediately think that means you're
racist or bigoted or homophobic or
something and it's it simply isn't the
truth learn how to sit with people in a
free society who are a little bit
different than you learn how to say with
people and change their minds but if you
think change you're gonna change
people's minds by drowning them out it
just doesn't work you may get some
temporary wins right you can get some
applause and you can get some temporary
wins but you will not win in the long
term because you will create a society
that simply will not be tolerant of you
one day because one day you will be on
the other side of it and there will be a
young person that believes in something
that you don't believe in or believe
something that you think is hate speech
and they will come for you too and the
only way thank you the only way the only
way to ensure protections for everybody
is to make sure that we're all treated
equally under the law and that's what
that's what we've got right now we got
some more moves from a white guy over
here all right what else where are we
all right so I just had a question just
because I want to clarify what you said
earlier about how you think we shouldn't
be passing laws against like speech that
could be hateful or is hateful or
whatever just because it's limiting
people's freedoms but I think what I
wanted to ask was so when you say like
limiting free speech
to some degree do you think that could
mean that you once you pass one law
that's limiting one thing for free
speech then it could turn into oh then
you're limiting another thing for free
speech and they like have this whirlwind
of then you live in a society where
people just can't say anything I feel
like it's too
I guess what sort I want to use its do
it up in the air to say that you can say
you can't say this thing you can't say
that thing like the government has to
take a very like MIT like you can't
defend you as a human being is different
than what will offend me so you can't
have subjective laws or leave it up to
the mob or to special interests or any
other group to say okay this is the
group of people we can't say anything
about or these are the words you can't
say or these are the people that you
account can't accidentally misgender and
again I say all of that within the
framework of you should and hopefully
will be respectful to people you will
hopefully treat people as individuals
and be willing to have friends of all
colors and ethnicities and all of that
stuff you guys have a question yeah you
have a question you have a question are
you guys the problem all right I think I
think you got the point there I think
you have a point there yes it is a
slippery slope if you say okay we can't
say this about X someone else is gonna
say you can't say this either okay and
then I feel like you could get to a
point where it's just like nothing can
be said and I feel like that's you
actually know you you are the problem
you got you almost got it
you almost got it you almost got it
except for the word not can we try that
one
see do you have a question perhaps
question groupthink man that's alluring
all right why don't you move on I'm just
gonna say that I feel like it's once you
open the door for one thing it can be
very dicey to enforce things without
infringing on rights because then you
could say that like oh saying everyone
should be equal is wrong if you had like
for example if you had like a lot of
people are concerned that Trump is a
white supremacist you guys ever played
the quiet game your quiet game let's see
how long you can do it if you have
people saying like Trump's a racist
Trump psycho white supremacist which is
like a very fair point to say because I
disagree with like a ton of the [ __ ] he
says he says like the stupidest [ __ ]
ever but if those people get in like the
majority of government and then they're
passing laws saying that you can't
preach for equality you can't say these
things like I feel like it's you can't
just have these subjective laws which I
like that's right employer trying to
make because you're completely right
like if you're pushing for people to
make subjective loss like hate speech is
always wrong but then if you have like
this majority fascists like a totally
racist group in place then they're gonna
try to pass oh well you can't say
everyone can be equal oh now we're gonna
have like white supremacist laws in
places you're trying to make that is the
point I'm trying to make you can't you
can't base laws on subjectivity you have
to base laws on equality we should have
laws in this country that make every
single person in this room equal it is
as simple as that
what's that equality does not exist
so
so can you give me give me a question or
something that I can respond to and I'll
gladly do that what quit what what what
was the question
you're allowed I said you asked me
several times and I repeatedly said yes
you're allowed to say hateful things it
sucks but you're allowed to say hateful
things that that's what happens okay
where are we down here here we'll go
here and then over there how's it going
I'm actually a pretty liberal dude a lot
of my friends are in turning-point so I
I came to help them out but she knows
who your friends are it's not so what I
love this event was supposed to be
surrounding cultural appropriation yeah
and I know that you didn't maybe get a
chance to really dive into that I know
you talked about like the the
overarching themes of regarding the
importance of free speech yeah but I
know that there's there's a lot of
differences when it comes to a college
campus and how people feel and I know
that on this campus you know we can have
our disagreements about what cultural
appropriation means or what role it
plays but there have been bias incidents
I think I'll there's been you know
things yet things that have happened
that have stemmed from racism and and I
know that this it shouldn't be a
government policy maybe to be
implemented but what steps you think the
administration can take to make sure
that we feel safe but also just as if
not more equally important people have
the right to free speech and that right
to think what they want well I think the
only thing that the government can do is
sort of what it has done generally which
is make sure that we all have equal laws
you can't have law
that say X people can do this and why
people can do this it's why marriage
equality was a just thing they wanted
equal rights not separate rights as for
cultural appropriation I mean I would I
would say do you think you should be
allowed to put dreadlocks in your hair
well so so my understanding of it was
more to the answer yes yes you yes you
can do whatever you want you can do
whatever you want with your body your it
is your body it's not their body you can
do whatever you want now you can be
respectful if you feel that's going to
offend people and you want to know more
about the history of dread lager and all
that but you if you if you pass if you
pass the capacity if you so I've never
heard of that I with that that's
completely so if that's what you're I
don't know about that specific instance
so you're telling me you you're giving
me an antique total story that a
hospital hired white people with
dreadlocks but not a black person with
dreadlocks I would need to know more
about that story but if you want to send
me a link I'll gladly look at it
I mean I'll gladly look at it of course
the hospital shouldn't be looking at
someone's skin colour at seton
so so what is it what so what is your
what is your solution what is your
solution
yeah the solution is all you can do is
create the conditions for more freedom
and hopefully you can educate people to
be better that's all you can do what so
you have to treat you have to show
people what is read images just to build
off the points I mean my understanding
was that cultural appropriation and
especially that the debates that we've
had over it here they have stemmed more
from intentionally putting people down
or attacking people that right where a
lot of the frustration I think has come
from yeah my question I guess was more
directed to do you think that a
university has a little bit more of a
role to play than the government in a
university can have a code of conduct
right especially a private university
can have all sorts of codes of conduct
and say if you treat your fellow student
this way or you treat your fellow
student that way that we are not going
to allow you to be a part of this
university or you won't be able to be
part of the Greek system or whatever it
is but also that's consistent with
everything else I believe which is that
it should be about local control so you
should ever in every situation the best
way for you to be governed is by your
own community every right we shouldn't
be handing off everything to the federal
government so I think one of the one
what's that you think you think right
now you think right now if it was up to
the states we would have slavery
well yes the fit yeah I'll talk to you
about it well I'm gonna deny the Civil
War no I'm not gonna deny the Civil War
the beauty of the States I would
recommend I would recommend an interview
I did with Randy Barnett who is a
constitutional law professor at
Georgetown and what he talks about is
the beauty of the States is that because
we have 50 states you if you don't like
what's happening in your state you can
move to another state you can move to
another state if you if California I
live in California there hold on
[Music]
No
what's that
I'm not even really sure what we're
debating here I assure you I am against
slavery I am a hundred percent for
equality for everyone so I don't I don't
know exactly what we're what we're
debating here right this way go down
here intellectual pluralism and that we
should have a plethora of ideas yes of
course of course I'm for all of these
people expressing their ideas what you
can't do is just drown out other people
from expressing theirs all right yeah
okay I mean I'm for anything I mean look
you could tell me we could sit there and
anyone here is welcome and that's why we
do Q&A is right it's for anyone to share
their views and then I can share my
views and then you go back and forth and
then you figure out what the best ideas
are that's the beauty of free speech no
I'm not here to teach you guys what to
think if you disagree with me that's
great
I just want us to be able to live in the
same society together I mean that's
that's it we should have the same laws
so that we can exist in the same society
but of course of course we should be
able to be debating ideas
[Applause]
yes to being on the left being
progressives do you feel threatened that
when you leave here well generally
speaking in America in 2018 the left and
an tyfa is more violent than the same
version on the right yeah but I'm not I
don't think you're gonna do I don't
think you're gonna do anything to me you
don't seem to like me very much I'm not
a victim I'll be all right I mean I'm
pretty quick a guy I can move on my feet
I'll be all right
yeah I don't think you are going to
yeah I don't think any I don't think
there's any reason to believe that any
of the people who have sat here
respectfully and quietly so you think
people outside are gonna come for the
people in this room regular basis
actually attack people of color I do or
minorities or people that are
transgender right and we have laws
against all of those things as we should
as we should as we should so we have
laws about those things I mean it
doesn't mean that it it doesn't mean
that the system is perfect it doesn't
mean that the system is perfect but we
have laws about those things I really
don't have a question for you because
you don't answer them so I'm just gonna
say this you said you said earlier and
the Supreme Court said we guys hate
speech was not a thing but we know
discipline culture food philosophy
Ferguson they ruled for Dred Scott and
the Weald for a ton of things that
pretty much put people of color and
people of color across the United States
in jeopardy they've made us feel like
second-class citizens and they've
actually legalized slavery they didn't
coach did a lot of things that made
people of color in this in this United
States feel like they were not part of
the country so when you talk about how
we talk about this because doing this
and doing that and turn that when you
talk about this because saying that
we've done that there's no such thing as
as what you call it again
let's hate speech it doesn't make any
sense because of course has no more
style than if they have been meeting
things they're wrong which means that
you have no point bringing up the
supreme courts as a moral standard of
saying that something exists when it
doesn't because it's a big Court does
not rule anything that makes any sense
anymore well there was a lot of things
in there that I didn't quite say but I
would agree that the Supreme Court in
and of itself is not the moral arbiter
and absolutely can they absolutely can
well because we're a nation of laws we
can debate we can debate hold on hold on
I let us yeah so just so just moving
back on the first time when you came in
and really started talking you talked
about how we had the Liberty another
such a validity said bringing the your
mat your poor masses for the masses and
they were separating and then you went
further on to say that we shouldn't have
an open bar we should allow illegal
immigrants into the country which is
basically just contradicting yourself
and then you talked about candy service
and you said how kind of service was
being supported by us and how that's a
great thing I think there's a YouTube
video of Candy's always talking about
how celebrities should not [ __ ] speak
because the he doesn't care about their
opinions so basically you're standing
there and you say something that's super
critical because they kinda switch to
talking about doesn't think the
celebrities have a right to speak which
means that you shouldn't even be using
highways as a moral standard or the
Supreme Court has a more silent because
all these people are people we know that
used to be [ __ ] so what you're saying
that you'd be saying so far is based on
crap because it makes no [ __ ] sense
my friend I I assume you didn't watch my
show this week I did a video about I did
a video about how you can't take Kanye's
word for gospel but what he did do was
give a little room I let you speak so
let me answer you and then we'll do it
again so that he that Kanye offered a
little oxygen for people to think a
little bit differently in the video that
I did just a few days ago I said I don't
know what his political beliefs are and
he might say something crazy tomorrow so
you can't take him as if he's the know
all in the end all on the be all that
why bring him up well because people
because ideas matter people matter he's
at whether you like Kanye or not he's a
mover of culture he's someone that moves
culture Wow no I I think the the the
basic thing in this room right now is
that we have people like you who go
around talking on Thursday I have no
clue about
handling and stuff so uh you don't you
don't you pretty much don't understand
the plight of people of color and
Crossley across the country so what do
we have that that is against you that's
not against me
really yeah really so like for example
they were there was a case of a student
athletes - student athletes the
committee that I had the rape case one
was black and one was white one good
three months in census the other one got
18 years so that shows you the one who
is injured was black at one who brought
me Maya is white white people excuse me
excuse me white people in this country
that I've been known to get less
sentences for the same crimes committed
as black people so that's what the
justice system in itself is basically
flaws which mean I say we're reforming
the justice system I've done plenty of
videos about that too but you're just
saying that we have long time they walk
so what's the whole point before why
would you want to reform a lot that
works you basically speaking from two
sides of your mouth you know what you're
talking about we listen my friend I am
completely down okay we're not friends
fine I am completely down to reform the
prison justice system I am completely
down to reform that
because I asked you because laws and the
justice system are not exactly the same
thing know what you're talking about is
that perhaps black people don't have
access to better lawyers because of
socio-economic reasons and a zillion
other things no it's not that okay okay
all right
how you doing good yep yeah so I know
that you mentioned that our country was
not founded on identity politics however
I want to note that women people of
color and other marginalized identities
we're not written into history and
therefore in the foundation of our
country for that matter so my question
here is how do you think everyone is
equal and represented if this country
was founded on the premise of exclusion
[Applause]
so I've talked about this a lot look is
there is there any question that George
Washington the Thomas Jefferson that
many of the other founders owned slaves
Thomas Jefferson owned slaves till the
day he died he had an affair with at
least one slave while at the very what
wait hold on while at the very same time
while at the very same time he was
writing the laws that ultimately would
free the slaves
so is he a per is he a perfect man is he
a perfect man he is not George
Washington the day he died his his half
of the slaves were freed but Martha
Washington kept her half is that just is
that just is that right no but these
people I would say this go to the
Jefferson Memorial in DC it's little off
the beaten path and and read and read
those documents there and these flawed
people who were just people of their
time they were writing the documents
that would ultimately give more freedom
to more people than any other country in
the history of the world it doesn't mean
it doesn't mean it doesn't mean that
they were always right and it doesn't
mean that they that they didn't have
their own prejudices it but they it
means that they were people who grew up
in a certain time and if the goal is to
always destroy the history to make a
future that you think is better you will
lose a lot by getting rid of that so I
would say they were imperfect people who
wrote some laws and wrote the basic
foundation of the Constitution and the
Bill of Rights that have guaranteed more
freedoms to more people than anywhere
else I think last one last one big
finish people so quick that Thomas
Jefferson was the third president right
and you're seeing him in Washington
we're writing laws to free slaves but it
wasn't until the 16th president that
those slaves wasn't even free along the
45th President and we're still dying
every day there was just a person that
was linked two days ago so I don't want
to hear this [ __ ] about hates me
does not free speech
quality exists nothing because this it
does it for you it does because you have
privilege the fact that you can stand
here and talk about the fact that people
can say slurs to you or whatever and you
can just walk outside it's okay no if
someone calls me the n-word I can get
shot so don't be telling me right now
that it doesn't exist and that's all I
have to say on that note all right you
know what for real guys
I've actually totally enjoyed this this
is this is what it's all about all right
settle down you don't own me you know I
mean relax lady I've actually really
enjoyed this this is what it's all about
and whether you disagreed with
everything I said are you agreed we did
a little something here you know what
and and I hope I hope perhaps that I
changed some of your minds and perhaps
some of those guys changed change your
minds and either right either way it's
all good as long as we don't walk out of
here at each other's throats and hurting
each other then then it's actually yeah
I don't sense I don't sense that any of
these calm people I'll bring you that
guys guys we're not gonna create any
acts of violence against any of these
people here tonight
all right well I have enjoyed this for
real hopefully next time Candice and and
Charlie will join for the festivities
and where do people get a beer here in
New Hampshire I'll find out about that
all right thank you guys